well the current line you're hearing
from Democrats is the president must be
impeached immediately for bribery even
though there's no evidence that he
bribed anyone well there is some
evidence that hunter Biden was in effect
bribed by a foreign government so why
aren't we investigating that question
Devin Nunez raised that query earlier
today after trying out several different
accusations against President Trump the
Democrats have recently settled on
bribery but if the Democrats in the
media are suddenly so deeply concerned
about bribery you would think they would
take some interest in burry smih pain
hunter Biden eighty-three thousand
dollars a month mark Hemingway is a
senior writer over real clear
investigations which does great work as
to see he joins this day mark thanks so
much for coming on should we be
concerned eighty-three thousand a month
from briefs but that seems like a fair
deal for doing what exactly this is a
good question the more we look at what a
hundred buttons arrangement with
Purisima was the more it doesn't make
sense
his lawyer put out a statement last
month saying was all about corporate
reform and transparency and he was
helping them with you know improved
their business practices while serving
on their board essentially but I got my
hands on report from a group called WAP
watchdog research in Florida and they
specialized in doing things like looking
at corporate governance and they look
closely this arrangement and it just
doesn't add up for one thing it Reuters
independently reported that there's
paperwork saying that he wasn't paid for
his board service which is what his
lawyer says he was paid for he was paid
for quote-unquote consulting services
not his board service now being a
consultant for a company at the same
time you're supposed to be an
independent member of the board if this
were a US company as opposed to a
Ukrainian company this might very well
be in violation of US securities laws so
really quick as anybody in the Obama
administration's foreign policy world
State Department NSC have they they must
have known about this if they said
anything about it not that I'm aware of
although it is interesting that it's
come out in the testimony last week that
the for the former ukrainian ambassador
Jovanovic she said that they prepped her
for a question for her Senate
confirmation hearing remember yeah
to deflect any questions worried I wish
we had more time thank you for pressing
on on this nope it'll come back more
coming away Thank You Sean Davis
co-founded the Federalist he's been one
of the most dogged reporters on the
subject from the very very beginning so
the hunter Biden story we're not I mean
are we asking too many questions about
it Sean is it do you think it's
unpatriotic to wonder why he made all
that money no there are too many
questions at all and I think everyone
should know why and how the vice
president's son who has no experience in
energy or Ukraine or business somehow
got paid a million bucks a year for who
knows what exactly I think we all
deserve answers on this especially if
we're going to be dealing with yet
another coup effort to throw the
president out of office because he had a
phone conversation some sniveling
mid-level bureaucrat didn't happen to
like do you think that that was more or
less on the level than his admission to
Yale Law School I can't speak to his his
law acumen so I don't know how to answer
that one yeah I'm starting to think the
system is rotten and I'm starting to
think that people who say that out loud
are in peril you're one of them so thank
you for coming on tonight appreciate it
Thank You Tucker